báo cáo mặt của hội đồng tình báo của Xan Mi A này C cho rằng các cuộc tấn công của sử
cuối mồ lượng nha bởi ra cũng khó có khả nân gián tư sự sử dụng của chính quyến này.
Các tùng tiên được báo Washington Post sẵn hại, mà lính giá được h案 tất thỏng một tôn chức
khi Mỹ và sự rào tiến hành các cuộc khu khu khu khu khu khu khách nhà bởi ra.
Báo cáo đã xem sinh như cái bản khăn nhau, từ các cuộc tấn công cuối mô hạm trẻ
đến trên sĩ của sử lơn hơn, đồng thời phân tích khả nân chuyển sắc quên lực chức
đạo các khá quý vàn bị loại bỏ.
Thuy đánh giá quế nâng xí, nếu cử kí lạnh tụt tôi cào ai li khi mình đây bị sách hại.
Cái tông chính chỉ quý vàn bản cân nhu cơ chế và kuy trình, nhằm giuy trình và đồng tụi bộ mạnh nhả nước.
Báo cáo cũng cho rằng khả nân cứ lực lượng lượng lập nghe trong sành quên kìm só chính quyền trong kịch bản này là phân cao.
Dên ngày phà lánh tính giá của giới tình gáo Mỹ, với mức độ ổn định của cố chức quên lực tại y vàn,
chứ bố cạnh các thằng của sử sát tăng.
Hình nhà chẳng chứ đứa ra bình luận vì việc tổng thống đương nân trong cố đu cùng các bạn đánh giá này.
Chứ khi quy định tế này chỉ có sự nhằm bảy ra khách không.
Theo Washington Post, báo cáo chú yếu tập chung và các kịch bản tính công tự xa và chưa hay lộ về cán nân trên khai lực rận bộ mình nghĩ trên lạnh tụt y vàn.